ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
ค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 25 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะอีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
0225 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤอาภาคมปีพตอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อสอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพ.ศ.อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลาบ่าย
15:00 นบ่าย 3 โมงกี่นาที 52
5 นาทีค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 52 นาทีก็เป็นเวลา
กลับอะเนาะตอนบ่ายแล้ว
ให้ห๊ากินข้าวกลางวันแล้วใช่ไหมคะกินข้าว
กลางวันแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงฟ้ากินข้าวกลางวัน
ตอนเที่ยงไหมใช่มากินข้าวกับวันตอน 12:20
น
12:20 น
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 15:00 น
50 เนาะใกล้ๆจะ 4 โมงแล้ว
เราก็ยังไม่กินข้าวเย็นเนาะห้องน้ำยังไม่
กินข้าวเย็นค่ะคุณว่าเราจะกินข้าวเย็น
เนี่ย 18:00 นพี่เขียนอะไรคะเนี่ย
เราจะกินข้าวเย็นเนี่ย 18:00 นเงินเย็นๆ
ถ้าเราก็หิวนิดหน่อยไหม
ใช่ค่ะหิวอ่ะหิวแต่ถ้ากินข้าวมันก็อิ่ม
ใช่กินข้าวก็อิ่มทีมได้
เอ้าก็ต้องกินผลไม้สิคะคุณฟ้าเอาโอ๋ผลไม้
ละไม้อัดจะเป็นแบบแตงโม
ใช่มั้ยแตงโมแม่
แตงโม
ซ่อม
ไม่ต้องรอ
ผลไม้กินผลไม้ก่อนหรือว่า
มะม่วง
มะม่วงใช่ไหมอ่ะกินผลไม้
[เพลง]
เอาอ๋ออ๋อผลไม้หรอผู้หญิงชอบกินผลไม้ไหม
ชอบกินครูฟ้าชอบน้ำผลไม้ใช่ไหมคะชอบมาก
อาจไม่มีเสียงแล้วค่ะ
ชอบมากค่ะใช่มั้ยแต่ผลไม้เนี่ยอะอย่างแตง
โมตรงเนี้ยสีเขียวเขียวของแตงโมสมัยแต่
ว่าถ้าเป็นตรงนี้
นี่แหละที่จริงมันเป็นสีแดงเนาะ
สีแดงแล้วก็มีเม็ดสีดำแล้วตรงสีเขียวของ
แตงโมหรือว่าข้างนอกของส้มของมะม่วงแหละ
เราเรียกอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เปลือกหักหญิงแล้วตรงสีแดงของแตงโม
เราเรียกอะไร
เนื้อ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินข้าวเปลือกหรือว่ากินเนื้อ
ของผลไม้
ลูกค้ากินเนื้อของผลไม้อ่ะไม่ถ้ากิน
เปลือกค่ะครูหญิงมั้ยเหลือแต่เราไม่กิน
ไม่กินไม่กินเวลาที่เรากินผลไม้เราก็ต้อง
ปอกเปลือกผลไม้
ปอกเปลือกหรอ
ใช่ไหมอ่ะอย่างส้มผู้หญิงมีส้มนะคะขอ
Stock  Share  screen ไปเลยนะคะผู้หญิง
least ภูฟ้าเนี่ยเขาชอบกินส้มและเกรียน
ว่าชอบกินส้มไม่ค่อยหญิงมีส้มล่ะอ่ะผู้
หญิงใช้เงินซื้อส้มมาค่ะ
ว้าว
ไม่ผู้หญิงดีเกินฮะหญิงรวยหักผู้หญิงเป็น
บิลเกตส์รู้
รวยไม่ไหวอ้าผู้ใหญ่หมี่ต้มใช่ไหมคะส้ม
เนี่ยตรงนี้นะเราเรียกว่าเปลือกส้มไม่กิน
on ต้มใช่ไหมคะเราไม่ได้เรากินเลยไม่ได้
นะถ้าเราต้องปอกเปลือกก่อน
โง่เรากินเลยไม่ได้หรอปอกเปลือกมันช้าอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าปอกเปลือกส้มยังไงครูฝาพูด
เดี๋ยวคุยอีกทำตามเพราะส้มเนี่ยมันจะมี
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมถ้านักเรียนเห็นคั่วอันนี้
คือหัวช่วยฟังหมดแหละเนาะแล้วก็นี้
ตุอื่นๆ
ก็ได้นะคะใช่ไหมอ่ะเอาโลโก้ออกเวลาครูฟ้า
ปอกเปลือกส้มครูฟ้าทำยังไงผู้พูดเดี๋ยว
พี่ทำตามกูฟ้าทำหรือว่าต้องหยิบส้มขึ้นมา
นะคะเก็บส้มพี่หมานี่มากูว่าก็หาหาอะไร
ฮ่าๆๆ
หาอะไรมีหรอกูฟ้าใช้มีปลอกส้มไหมไม่
โอ้นี่หาพี่นะเรียนไม่หามีดฟ้าหาตรงที่
มันเป็น
ต้นมันไหนหวนนี้หรอๆตรงเนี้ยขอตรงที่เป็น
จุดบุอยู่ที่ก้นของส้มอ่ะกูฟ้าหาเจอแล้ว
เขาก็เอาเล็บได้ทุกคนมีเล็กไปคะเล็บนะ
เล็บ
เล็บจิกระไวนิ้วไหนคะนิ้วโป้งค่ะผู้หญิง
ช่วยก็ได้ไม่เอาค่ะอันนี้ใช่ไหมตรงกลาง
ที่รู้ฟ้าแล้วก็เอานิ้วเนี่ยจิกลงไปจิตลง
ไปแล้วก็แกะแกะ
เดี๋ยว
ใช่ภูฟ้าแกะสัตว์ตูดส้มแท็กนะคะรสผู้หญิง
เนี่ยอุ้ยเลยเห็นมั้ยใช่มั้ยว่ามีขั้วของ
ส้มเป็นหัวหมีชอบเด็ดออกนะคะไม่ชอบนะคะ
ให้มันจะเห็นเมย์ใช่ไหมกูหญิงเนี่ยทำ
เหมือนครูฟ้านะใครนิ้วโป้งเหมือนกันแล้ว
อาจิลงไปแต่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยทั้งหัวใจจะหัว
มันจะยากเนาะเออตูดมาติดง่ายนะผู้หญิง
เฮ้ยแค่แล้วก็ปลอกเปลือกอ่าเห็นไหมเค้า
บอกเสียก็เหนื่อยเว้ยออกก็ไม่น่ากินเลย
ค่ะนักเรียนส้ม for ส่งไม่อร่อยใช่ไหมหา
นักเรียนดูเนี่ยส้มถ้ามีสีขาวๆแบบนี้เรา
เรียกว่ามันฝ่อไม่อร่อยกูฟ้าแล้วครูฟ้า
เนี่ยแกะแกะใดของต้มออกไหมเวลาจะกินส้ม
ใหญ่ส้มเนี่ยไม่แกะใหญ่ส่งค่ะครูฟ้ากิน
ใหญ่ส้มเพราะว่ายายส้มมีวิตามินใช่มั้ย
abcdef  senior  with  a  knife ใหญ่ทรง
นักเรียนเห็นเนาะมีวิตามินลูกค้าแล้วกู
ปลาได้ส้มแล้วเวลากูมากินส้ม
หมดเลยมั้ยหิวมากกินทีละ kreme อีกทีละ
กลีบหาที่รัก Rate งั่ม
อิ่มน้ำ
นิดเดียวกันนี้ก็คือปลอกเปลือกส้มง่ายๆมี
อะไร
ปอกเปลือกทุเรียนเหรอคะ
ไม่เเพงเด็ก
กูฟ้าจะปอกเปลือกทุเรียนหรอเปล่าก็ให้ดู
เปลี่ยนทุเรียน
อันนี้ต้องเก่งมากๆนะคนจะปอกเปลือก
ทุเรียนเนี่ยครูหญิงปอกเปลือกทุเรียนไม่
ได้ผู้ค้าได้ไหม
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้แล้วส้มเนี่ยเก่งส้มเนี่ย
ง่ายๆนะๆมีอันนึงอันนี้เราต้องใช้อุปกรณ์
ในการปลอกเปลือกเพราะว่าส้มเนี่ยเราไม่
ต้องใช้อะไรเราใช้แค่มือเล็บมือของเรา
ขอให้ผู้หญิงนี้ผลไม้อีก 1 อย่างค่ะครู
ฟ้า
ผลไม้อะไรนะคุณหญิง
อันนี้เป็นไฟล์ได้ยินเสียงผู้หญิงปกติ
เนาะ
ปกตินะคะได้ยินผู้หญิงมี
เอาอะไรครับรูฟ้า
มะละกอ
มะละกอมาหามาแล้วก่อนเนี่ยถ้านักเรียน
เห็นสีส้มตรงนี้ก็คือเปลือกของมะละกอเรา
ก็ไม่กินมหาไม่กินแต่นี่เป็นมะละกอสุกนะ
ไม่เอาไปทำส้มตำเป็นผลไม้
อันนี้เป็นมะละกอที่เรากินกันนะฮะแต่เรา
ไม่กินเปลือกไม่เปลือกมันก็จะมีหัวเนาะ
แล้วก็ตูดนะฮะ 2 มาละเกาะเวลาที่เราปอกมา
แล้วจอนะคะเราใช้แค่มือเดียวไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้เรามให้อะไรอยู่ผู้หญิงเราต้องใช้
มีดค่ะนอมีมีดมีกรีดยังมีผู้หญิงนะนิดนึง
คมวันที่สุดในบ้านแล้วค่ะ
แล้วนี่ยังไงอ่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนะผู้หญิง
ตอบมาแล้วนะคะผู้หญิงก็จะตัดนะหาเอา
มีดแหละนะคะหันหัวมันแหละครัวมันตรงนี้นะ
คะทิ้งก่อนอันนี้ล้างแล้วหลานแล้วนะ
ล้างน้ำแล้วแล้วผู้หญิงว่าตัดหัวทิ้งจริง
แล้วก็ตัดก้นก้น
ทิ้งนะคะแล้วก็เวลาที่เราปลอกเนี่ยปอก
เนี่ยนะคะเราก็จะเอามือใช่ไหมเราวางแบบ
นี้แล้วก็เอามาแล้วกองวางที่มือซ้ายหรือ
ซ้ายนะว่ากูหญิงเนี่ยถนัดมือขวาและมือ
ซ้ายก็คือเวลานักเรียนแต่งงานอะเนาะขอ
แหวนชายผู้หญิงเนี่ยถนัดมือขวาก็จะใช้มือ
ขวาเนี่ยจับนี่ตแล้วก็ปลอกมะละกอ
นักเรียนแล้วค้นหาไอ้เนี่ยเวลาที่เราจับ
มะละกอแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคนไทยเนี่ยเราปล่อยออก
จากฝั่งที่อยู่ใกล้เราหรือว่าจะหนีแล้ว
หัวดีถ้านักเรียนจะเอาควบต้นอะไรที่อยู่
ใกล้เราเราจะเอามีดเนี่ยปอกจากตรงนี้แล้ว
ก็ออกออกออก
และหน้าแล้วปอกๆอ๋อแปลกมาก
ทำไมแปลกอ่ะกูฟ้านี่ให้เราบอก
ผู้หญิงปลอกมาแล้วก็เก่งมากเฮ้ยกูพูดจริง
เหรอไปหาทำไมไม่รู้เหมือนกันพูดไปเฉยๆอ่ะ
You  can  i คู่ฟ้าครูหญิงเคยเห็นนัก
เรียน
ไม่รู้แต่ไม่ได้คนประเทศอะไรเวลานักเรียน
มีผลไม้มันหนักนะคะนักเรียนที่ต้องตอบ
เหลือดและพริกน่ะจับมีดใช่ไหมคุณคนไทยจะ
จอดนี่แบบนี้กับที่ด้านของมีดแล้วก็แบบ
นี้แหละเราจะมีนิ้วชี้เนี่ยไว้ที่วางไว้
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมนั้นก็แบบนี้เดี๋ยวเอาไว้
ล็อคที่เปลือกเนี่ยคนไทยจะทำแบบนี้นัก
เรียนเห็นหรอเห็นหน้าเนี้ยคนไทยปลอกแต่
ผู้หญิงเคยเห็นนักเรียนน่ะตอบผลไม้อาจจะ
เป็นมะละกอมะม่วงนักเรียนเนี่ยจับมีดแล้ว
ก็แบบอย่างเงี้ยแล้วนักเรียนและก็บอกเข้า
มาหาตัว
ไม่ยากไม่ต้องเป็นมาแล้วก่อนที่ชิ้นเล็ก
หน่อยนะคะเดี๋ยวก็วิ่งหันครึ่งก่อนได้ไหม
ได้เอาหญิงนักเรียนปลอกผลไม้เนี่ยที่เป็น
องค์กรหรือว่าอะไรที่ต้องใช้หนี้ตนัก
เรียนจะปอกเข้าเข้าเข้านี้หรอคือคนไทย
เนี่ย 0 หันครึ่งน้อยแต่ว่ามันจะมีเม็ดนะ
คะมีเบสนะนักเรียนเนี่ยต้องคนไทยแล้วปอก
ออกจากตัวสมัยออกไปแต่เคยนักเรียนนัก
เรียนจับมีด
กับนี่แล้วก็บอกเนี้ยสมมตินะเห็นไหมเนี่ย
อ่ะตอนนี้แล้วกันนักเรียนเนี่ยปอกเข้าก็
ทำให้เป็นนะไม่ใช่คนไทยไงยะๆก็บอกเข้า
แล้วโจทย์เราเหรอคะนักเรียนนี่นะกลัวนะ
ไม่เพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยปอปออกเห็นไหมเราจะ
บอกแล้วก็เอานิ้วชี้เทคนิคนะคะนิ้วชี้
เนี่ยล็อคที่เปลือกเอาไว้
แต่มะละกอเนี่ยนะคะมันเป็นผลไม้ที่มีเม็ด
บ้างเนี่ยบางคนเขาก็จะผ่านั่นผ่าครึ่ง
เต็ม
ที่มืออย่างนี้เลยนะบางคนแบบกิ่งมากๆนะคะ
หาครึ่งแล้วก็เม็ดใช่ไหมคะเม็ดเนี่ยไม่
กินไม่กินไม่กิน
คนเราเนี่ยจะมีช้อนผู้หญิงไม่มีช้อนอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวเขายิงเขาเดินเอาช้อนแป๊บนึงได้ไหม
คะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะผู้หญิงได้ก็เนี่ยผู้หญิง
ก็ไปเอาช้อนนะคะเพราะว่ามะละกอเนี่ยก็จะ
มีเม็ดใช่ไหมเม็ดสีดำที่นักเรียนเห็นเม็ด
มะละกอไม่กินนะคะไม่กินต้องมีช้อนแต่ไป
ถอนพูดออกสมัยขูดแบบนี้นะ
คู่คูณเม็ดก็
เห็นไหมเนี่ยเห็ดเนาะ
ใส่ค่ะเพราะเราไม่กินแล้วนะเราก็ไม่เอา
มันขมา
พ่อแม่หน่อยตายเราก็จะขูดเม็ดนะคะขูดเม็ด
ออก
ง่ายๆเสร็จแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่แล้วเราก็ตรงนี้มันเป็นขั้วแข็งๆใช่
ไหมคะเราไม่เอาแล้วก็จะเอามีดและหันโลไป
เป็นเหมือนสามเหลี่ยม
แบบนี้แล้วก็เอาออกนะคะแล้วเวลาปอกก็คือ
ตอบออกจากตัว
ใช่เพราะเราต้องเซฟตัวเองเราจะให้เท่า
เกิดมันทำยังไงคะเห็ดนักเรียนน่ะปลอกเข้า
แบบเนี้ย
ฮ่าๆช่วยแพทย์ไม่โดนหน้าเราเหรอคะเออต้อง
เรียนวิเลปนอื่นใช่ก็ไม่แน่ใจว่านักเรียน
ทุกหลายๆประเทศเนี่ยเวลาปอกผลไม้เหมือน
กันไหม High เคยเห็นนักเรียนต่อแบบเนี้ย
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็เคยเห็ต่อไปพอเราปอกเสร็จ
แล้วอสูรเป็นมะละกอใช่ไหมคะคนไทยเนี่ยอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็จะหั่นอีกครึ่งนึงสะพานครึ่ง
หั่นครึ่งแล้วก็เหมือนอีก
นะคะอันในครึ่งฉันในครึ่งใช้มะละกอ
เครื่องรูปแล้วก็ที่เป็นครึ่งปุ๊บเป็น
เครื่องแบบนี้เราก็จะได้มะละกอ 1  2  3  4
4 ชิ้นนะคะแล้วก็หัน
แล้วก็กินได้นะอ้ำยังไม่กินนะคะนักเรียน
ทำไมผู้หญิงปีสอนอยู่ไงกินก็ไม่ดีใช่ไหม
คะเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าเห็นแล้วแบบ
อ้าว
ฟ้ามันก็โตหวานมากเลยอ่ะขอบคุณค่ะผู้หญิง
ที่บอกมาส่งไหมไม่เห็นด้วยค่า
ส่งเคอรี่ไปให้กูฟ้าปีกไม่รู้ว่าจะมาแล้ว
ก็ไปวางไว้ที่ไหนดีนะคะ
วันนี้หรอ
ที่เราสอนนะเดี๋ยวก็หมดเวลาแล้วไงอ่ะนี่
นะคะก็เป็นการปลอกเปลือกผลไม้ไม่ว่าจะ
เป็นมะละกอ
มะม่วง
หรือส้ม
ไม้ที่ต้องใช้มีดล่ะค่ะนักเรียนใช้มีดใน
การปลอกเนี่ยคนไทยและเราปอกๆออกจากตัว
สาธุภูฟ้าอยู่เหม่งออกไปน่ะเราก็ไปหากุล
ฝา
คืนเล่าเรียนอาจจะคิดว่าเราต้องเซฟคนอื่น
ไหมก็เลยต้องศอกเค้าไม่อ่ะคนไทยเฟสตัวเอง
นะคะขอบคุณท่านนักเรียนเข้าแล้วมีคนเนี่ย
เจิญมาชนใช่ไหมชนข้อสอบ
อันตรายนะคะ R
แต่ถ้าเราตอบออกแบบนี้
ครูฟ้าเห็นมีดตรงชนคมใช่ไหมภูฟ้าก็ไม่
อยู่ใกล้ๆไงว่ากูฟ้าก็กลัวครูหญิงปลอบออก
ไปแล้วไปโดนครูฟ้าหรือว่ามีคนเดินมาแล้ว
ชนก็ไม่พ้นเรานี่แหละเห็นวิธีการปอก
เปลือกผลไม้ของคนไทยนะไม่รู้ว่าประเทศนัก
เรียน
ต่อไหมออก
หรือบอกเข้าหรือว่านักเรียนนักเรียนแหละ
บอกๆหรือต่อเข้านักเรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลา
แล้วใช่ไหมพูดแล้วเราก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าต่อค่ะหนิงขอตัว
ไปกินมะละกอก่อนนะคะผัวมาแล้วก็อร่อยมาก
จะต้องไปกินส้มใช่ไหมคะส่งก็พี่บอกไปแล้ว
ด้วยนะคะแต่สวัสดีค่ะแล้วกินส้มไม่ได้นะ
สวัสดีค่ะเปรี้ยวบ๊ายบายๆ
[เพลง]